this is the Jocko underground podcast
sitting here with Echo Charles
yeah that's right yeah I'm sitting here
with Echo Charles
we were gonna I I proposed you're back
from Hawaii I figure you're ready to get
back in the game on the mats of Justice
I sent you a text hey train at this time
we'll record done when we're done yeah
denied
you did not want to do it you did not
want to partake I had literally zero
percent interest in taking you up on
that why okay well okay I don't want to
make this too long of a story but we do
run that risk so if a bunch of people
just left in the chat
food stuff
first off you're correct I am back from
Hawaii and I am back in the game 100 so
in Hawaii it was let's say it was a
slacker trip okay a little bit Yeah I
worked out a little bit but I drank a
lot of beer
um not gut we partied or nothing like
this but like you know and I don't
really drink that much beer
so anyway diet kind of fell off anyway
so when I get back and you know we all
feel like that when we get back from
vacation I'm getting I'm going hard in
fact setting straight up goals with
numbers with numbers
check this brother out so anyway the
past week has been strong strong like on
the path good numbers way ahead I'm
ahead of schedule
is on the schedule and has been I've
been training all week
um lifting everything okay when you
texted me today right
a
Jiu Jitsu trading was not part of the
schedule because I have a schedule like
I have a plan like I'm training this day
this day this day Jiu Jitsu you should
always be on the schedule every single
day yes so yeah I'm not there
yet okay that's not that's not where I'm
at on the in the program see what I'm
saying okay so anyway
and I'm like in the middle or in the
middle of my workout literally in the
middle of my work at 10 o'clock in the
morning and you're over here
and you're over here
anyway
I'm currently training like a lunchtime
workout starts at 11 30. yeah a morning
workout goes until 7 38. hey man what
are you doing at 10. we'll call it a
brunch we have some people in town we
hung out in the morning a little bit you
know I got to the workout hit it hard
all good but in the middle of it day and
here comes your kind of lift towards it
what did you do
okay so gosh that was a bad question
yeah you're about to get detailed way
more detailed than anybody put it this
way I did a shoulder circuit okay I did
an arm circuit and then I did a magcon
yeah like a aerodyne thing anyway the
air assault bike so you were tired I was
in the middle of a workout
so you can't just roll in spontaneously
changing the whole program can't do that
it's not how it's going you know that's
not how the workout uh program works so
you say let's train which is going to be
like less than however many hours and I
said let's train after we get done
recording correct and you said no to
that too nope wasn't part of the program
not part of the program
so I like how that's in your mind that's
justification yeah like that's
legitimate you might as well have just
said that's against the law or against
the Constitution of the United States of
America that's how you're talking right
now because Jiu Jitsu wasn't
predetermined correct so here's the
weird thing freaking ridiculous what you
just said right there you're you're like
you're on you're on to some is because I
thought to myself like why wouldn't I
because I felt a pressure you know when
you're like you know when someone asks
you to train and yeah you know what you
should morally do you know what the
right thing to do is I wouldn't go that
far but a little bit of that what you
just said is true because it's kind of
like hey it's not like I don't want to
train it's not like I don't want to do
like I feel like me saying no to
training is me saying no to a training
opportunity it's what it felt like
especially you did you
Jocko have a way and I think other
people can vouch for this you have a way
of like saying stuff without saying
stuff it's a taxi bro it's a text I said
do you want to train it and then we
record afterwards so you can imagine how
powerful that is
oh so I feel it and I felt it there's no
exception you're like oh yeah let's
train I was sending brain negative brain
waves towards you oh yeah loud and clear
but every once in a while so now I'm in
a conundrum like do I do I give in to
Jocko's freaking pressure it's positive
peer pressure exactly right so now you
can imagine my would you feel better if
we trained no right now no you got to be
kidding me well then again I don't know
so the answer honestly if we would have
trained right now had a good role did
six seven rounds pretty chill
and you would not feel better right now
I don't know yeah this is what I'm going
through In My Head by the way to justify
me saying no and not feel like guilty or
whatever so but then but then I I
thought back to my whole like
my whole life
it's just a text bro
I got back to my whole life when I
started like working out and doing stuff
and when I first learned about like
working out in programs and stuff
I've always done that I always like even
if it's like good for me it's not part
of the program I'm not doing it
if I do something different than the
program how do I know if this program
actually works if I didn't follow it
correctly right so but then I got so
like so strict to that idea that it kind
of mutated into this like so how to
drink and beer in Hawaii and not working
out for three weeks how'd that fit on
the program that was not on the program
okay but nonetheless that's what I was
like contemplating in my head but here's
the thing look after workout I go into
recovery period
with you by the way is not a recovery
period oh that is the opposite of
recovery period so anyway
so we did not train no we did not train
today maybe we'll train tomorrow
actually tomorrow I have off so it don't
even bother me tomorrow
okay all right well here we are we can
can you do this can you make it through
this or do you get K dog in here get
carry in here because you're recovering
right now
you gotta go use a theragon on your on
your shoulder whatever bro whatever but
it's true it's true
all right well
um Talk
a little bit I got to ask a question
um the topic the topic is is a common
topic that you hear a lot of people say
it's you know
um with social media out there
no one there's no consequences
right and someone's asking me you know
hey
isn't it seem like social media has no
consequences
and it's just it just makes anybody able
to say anything yeah and and that seemed
like a really good launch point for me
to like launch into like hell yeah
social media no more no one would say
that to my face
they would have to pay for that kind of
thing and
and I was my actual response was
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground